[Music]  it's time for a tease social study your  quick look at what the stars are posting  online I'm so having so much fun first  check out Gwen Stefani's new Twitter  profile pic yep it's an old photo of  boyfriend Blake Shelton with a mullet  because was like such a different world  she's always fun for me demi lovato and  boyfriend gear may bamba vasconcelos  also being cute we had a group trip to  Disneyland to celebrate his birthday on  Thursday I'm just having fun you know  and my life is in a really good place  right now and watch this snippet Demi  kissing her man's chief the MMA fighter  captioned this shot I love you it feels  amazing Demi also snapchatted this solo  pic check out the bling on that finger  meanwhile Ava Mendes stunned at the  grand opening of new york and companies  Miami store she has her own new line  with the brand she posted this to  instagram writing our latest collection  has my favorite color combo of all time  pink and green  [Music]  you  [Music]